such a long string in numbers and I
think it's enough to label every atom in
the universe or something is this one of
those very big numbers at least in
computer terms but we physicists might
disagree IP is Internet Protocol IP
number is they used to address it so
these are these are used to let you get
data to a particular place in a
particular machine and that's what going
that's the function your IP address
those IP addresses in particular do
examples of ipv4 so this is the kind of
current Internet
it's called version four I don't think
inversions 1 2 3 were ever really
deployed it's been version 4 since the
seventies so the sort of examples you
might see this kind of thing with the
you know one 28.24 3.30 5.9 so at one
point that was the IP address of one of
my computers here I don't think it is
currently this is an IP address in
what's called dot int quad notation so
you've got dots and you've got four four
bytes each of these numbers here will be
less than or equal to 255 because 255 is
the biggest decimal number you can
represent in a single byte you have this
dotted quad notation and that will get
turned into in an IP packet into just a
series of bits okay so I'm not gonna try
and do the binary all in my head but
it's gonna be something I think that if
I'm a variety will be kind of 128 243
similarly all the way through to 9 which
would be 1 0 0 1 ok so that's just gonna
be this sequence of bits is your IP
address
no ipv4 address by putting that sequence
of bits in the right place at the start
of your packet it's gonna get treated as
a destination address by all the routers
on the path you imagine the internet as
a sequence of reuters that are all sort
of connected in some means like this
then if your packet comes in here and
it's trying to get to some guy now here
it's gonna get to this route to here and
that route I have to make a decision
which way to send it and it's gonna do
that using longest prefix match on the
destination address look it up in the
table and decide should it send it out
of you know interface a or interface B
so their route is going to receive your
data they're gonna pull off whatever the
stuff on the front of it at least that
headers and so on you might be they're
gonna get an IP packet which is gonna
have an IP header and some data
following it and
had are they gonna go and look in a
particular location they had to see this
sequence of bits then they're gonna look
that sequence of bits up in the table
the entry that matches the best match
they can find the so-called longest
prefix match so the longest sequence
from the start all the way back that
just matches exactly on those bits will
point to particular entry in my table
and that entry in that table will say
which network interface it should
transmit it here talking usually so who
decides what these rooms are so these
numbers get assigned hierarchically so
there's a body call Diana the internet
assigned numbers Authority I think I get
that right but basic this is the body
which has administrative control over
all of these numbers it will hand them
out to the regional authorities so there
might be one for in Europe like the one
for Asia Pacific then like the one for
North America and then those bodies will
hand them out to be perhaps national
authorities so I might have to act at UK
you might hand it out to in with your
states as on and so this prefix here
which always refers to the first 16 bits
has been handed out at the University
not here so university knocking
computers will typically be I don't know
if we have all the prefixes but
certainly many of them will be within
that prefix so that means that any
packet on the internet that has that
prefix at the beginning of an address in
the destination address field will
eventually wind its way towards our
computers here in Nottingham
there are a lot more computers in the
world than that can deal with surely
there are nowadays yeah back in the day
there weren't so many foot yeah now
there are and that's one of the reasons
ipv6 was perceived as having a great
benefit just the amount of addresses in
it so I think me six instead of being 32
bits so four bytes is on in 28 bits so
it's just much bigger addresses to 2028
is a very large number at least in
computer terms and one of the reasons
ipv6 took a long time to kind of take
off was that essentially is quite lot of
cost implications because you have to
upgrade the software and in some cases
probably the hardware is and results of
lots of the rooters that live inside
these networks and you had to get
software installed on you know you've
got to get your home routers able to
support this stuff you've got to get all
the software stacks and networking
product
that's on your devices to support this
stuff so Windows have to be updated to
support new T six example and it has
done for some time there but that was a
process that had to go for him that was
a new piece of software implementation
then you have to get right tested I kind
of stuff a bunch of services that need
to be upgraded to support ipv6 so for
example the name translation service DNS
is the protocol that lets you translate
that google.com name into the IP address
when that was designed and developed
pypy before was anything the only IP
going and so that whole DNS
infrastructure have to be upgraded and
updated to support this new protocol so
there's quite a lot of sort of knock-on
effects of updating this and it's not as
simple as just saying one will have more
bits of the address there's lots of
other interpreter interdependent
services that have to also support that
and I think the amount of complexity
that was there perhaps was surprising
how expensive it was to go through that
process
it took longer to get ipv6 deployed than
expected and the that's still kind of
going on although they're starting to
see deployment now people had to come up
with other ways of dealing with that
when you've got too many machines and
not enough addresses so that's where you
get NAT NAT is network address
translation we don't have enough
addresses to represent every machine so
what we can do is we can kind of faith
things out